is Africa poor because of colonialism
resounding no the solution to Poverty is
prosperity then who and how do we build
prosperity it's entrepreneurs right they
always have two companies one in the in
Africa and one in the US and to see that
one almost took two years the other one
barely 20 minutes to put together why is
it so over regulated that because once
upon a time we drank the Fateful ill
advised Dreadful deadly ideology of
socialism oh my God great to have you on
the show thanks for having me both of
you uh one of the questions that has
been suggested to us to ask because we
obviously ask our fans Etc what we
should talk about is colonialism and
Africa this is something you talk about
a lot is Africa poor because of
colonialism resounding no it's
not I mean think about it
um people like you know when you line up
you could line up a 100 people African
non-african doesn't matter and you start
asking questions and you might probably
get a hundred different answers but you
can pretty much cater
croize I told you English is only my my
fourth language so some of these words I
don't know how to pronounce you can put
it into categories let's say and uh some
people anywhere so the people who
are some people will be like on the IQ
thing lazy thing you know that whole
racist trend of why Africans are where
they are today and then you have exactly
and then you have you sounded like
you've done a lot of research
in I GRE up in South London mate me
right and so on the other end you have
Africans and their allly so-called
allies and um for them it's all various
forms of victimhood you know anywhere
from it's because of racism it's because
you know we've been colon colonized it's
because they're stealing our natural
resources you hear all of that yet I
don't hear anyone talking about what's
the reason why we're still poor and so
what do I mean mean by
that think about it we are talking about
poverty you asked me the question is
Africa poor poor today because of
colonialism you said poverty you didn't
say anything else poverty what's the
solution to Poverty isn't it prosperity
it's not poverty alleviation like this
idea that I should just be happy being a
little bit less four but it's pathetic
so the solution to Poverty is prosperity
then who and how do we build prosperity
it's entrepreneurs right traditionally
Any Nation you look at it's it's
entrepreneurs that did it well what do
entrepreneurs need in order to
thrive they need an enabling business
environment and we find that actually
business um countries that offer their
citizens a world-class business
environment are rich conversely those
who offer a pretty bad poor business
environment don't Thrive and about
corruption well no not not exactly
corruption it's it's it's a pile of
different things so I could could walk
you into all of this for example take my
country Sagal um you know when I started
my first company back in
2003 so at that point when you wanted to
start a company you know you have to
register the business first of all how
long would it take back in the days
almost two years to register the the
business legally and you look at that
and you thought about the sister company
because I always have two companies one
in the in Africa and one in the US ver
sister the companies and to see that one
almost took two years the other one
barely 20 minutes to put together in
this instance you married to your
employees for good or for bad over here
employment at will and so on and so
forth It's about everything like that
everything if I want to hire if I want
to hire you if I want to hire
you if I want to hire you Francis the
deal is simple I show up we write a
contract done you put it in in your
drawers I put it in my drawers we're
done mhm but in senagal I want to hire
Conant we're over there talking to each
other ever I have to get a contract in
free exampler examples take myself
physically to a government's office
called
inspection where there we meet with a
government official who doesn't know the
first thing about my business probably
never ran a business in his whole da
life probably maybe never was in the
private sector has no idea what we're
doing doesn't even know where we are but
this person gets to decide if Conant and
I get to work together or not and says
well where is his um where is his uh
health certificate showing me that he is
apt to do the
job see this type of nonsense when you
put all of this together that's what the
economist call economic freedom and so
and that's also part of that's also what
we call the business environment
technically how free or not are you to
Enterprise how how free or not are you
to run the business and so when you
realize that Africa is the region in the
world that's the most over regulated
region in the world that's the one that
offers its entrepreneurs the least
freedom to Enterprise then you
understand why are we're
poor poverty solved by Prosperity
Prosperity built by entrepreneurs
entrepreneurs need a business class
business environment it happens to be
that in Africa they have the worst
business environments in the world you
haven't looked there and you want to sit
there and scream about all of these
so-called reasons as to why we're
supposedly poor give me a break give me
a break so this is what we have found
and that's what we need to work on and
no one is working on because there 100
people I told you about you line them up
you ask them why we're poor none of them
none of them speaks about the shackles
that are around my neck as an
entrepreneur trying to do business Ong
ground good luck with that why is it so
over regulated though because once upon
a time we drank the
Fateful ill advised Dreadful deadly
ideology of socialism and I will try to
you describe here what socialm means you
know because our friends our friends who
feel victimized all the time and our
young people who think socialism is a
good idea you know for them when they
think about socialism is just like oh
everybody's provided for what they need
and all of that but no it's uh you know
the the government owning you know the
means of production so or when the
econom is completely planned from the
top down so what happened Francis
is when we got out of slavery we got
into
colonialism and towards um the end of
colonialism what we had was the
liberators of Africa so all over the
continent we had various people fighting
for uh you know the freedom of their
Nations and so what you had is around um
right before the independences in the
late 50s early 60s what you had was um
basically you were for people who know
our history we were at the at the height
of uh this ideological battle on on one
end represented by the Western Nations
practicing you know uh capitalism and
what they were promoting was Freedom
facing off with the Eastern block you
know um promoting various forms of
statism and the both blocks were looking
for influence usually looking down south
and so we were no different they were
looking for influence with us as well
and so that's when our people especially
the many of these liberators of Africa
they're thinking okay the West is who
colonized us whatever they're standing
for we cannot be for and they threw the
baby out with the bath water that's when
we made the faithful decision to side
with uh the social the Marxist socialist
of back then that's
how as most African nations were
starting to become free most of these
leaders were also so socialist leaders
and as you know this thing doesn't
happen in a vacuum you just don't be
like Oh I'm a socialist and it doesn't
show anywhere else so everything is uh
following you know the Socialist
ideologies basically um all of these um
what do you call them uh this fiveyear
plan Soviet style that's what almost all
African nations had and then some people
were like well Nigeria was not social
well Nigeria still was doing a five-year
plan on a Soviet style and so this is
what happened to us and we to this day
have not reconsidered any of us any of
us because when I go and um this
gentleman is telling me you have to uh
you have to bring me your um your
constant's um health certificate and I'm
asking where is it in the law and they
open it and I look at the date and it
from the colonial
times so yeah this is this is how we
became socialist but no one sees that
today because what the world sees is
it's so funny because I talk to people
even on the right and they say what do
you mean Africa is this Lawless land so
for most people there's no law going on
in Africa it's like every man for
themselves and my fellow Africans also
feel the same way because they'll be
like what do you mean that Sagal and uh
in general Africa um is the region in
the world where the employees are the
most protected I'm like yes on paper
this is the region of the world where
employees are the most protected around
the world and they're like which AFC do
you live in because the Africa I live in
and I and I and I'm in every day uh I
see people who have not been paid for
eight months I see people who are
treated like crap at their jobs I see I
don't see protected people I say I'll
explain what you see is the result of us
on paper I take my country Sagal is one
of the countries where the employees are
the most protected in the world what
does it uh how does it translate for us
we're one of the 25 poorest countries in
the world what people need to understand
is the law is the
law if you make it super an employee
being super protected means there's tons
of Labor regulations that stand in the
way that at will employment that I get
in the US absolutely not over here
because remember the government gets to
tell me when we can hire each other when
I need to get rid of you even if you're
stealing from me the government has to
sanction that decision so the government
makes a decision as to when and how much
it's going to cost me to get rid of you
even if you're at risk and then what
does it mean most people don't want to
hire people full-time so they play with
a with a law around the they basically
hire somebody for two years as a
contractor right before the two years is
over you need to leave then come back
two days later or a week later because
that way we can start over again because
if you try to renew those contracts
after two times it turns into an
indefinite contract and when that
happens it means you a full-time you're
now an employee you're considered like
this is it it's almost like a permanent
situation and so I tell people think
about it if you're about you fall in
love and you're about to marry and I say
to you uh Conant be very careful because
you know this person you're about to
marry for whatever reason no matter what
happens and you need to divorce you
can't divorce do you think you're can
ever get married no so I tell people if
I can't fire you I can't hire you I know
it sounds cruel but it makes sense right
and so this is what we have so what
happens is because the laws are so
cumbersome almost no one wants to set up
a business at least not a legal business
there's a reason why there's 97% of um
businesses in Sagal that are in the
informal sector I repeat 97% of the
businesses in Sagal are the in the
informal sector it's directly correlated
correlated to what I just explained
people are not stupid uh and the reason
I asked about corrupt ear is I know from
Russia for example where it's not as bad
in terms of regulations Etc but the
reason that these restrictions and these
appara and these bureaucrats exist to
get involved in your business is because
they get to exercise power over a
business and then they can say well you
know I could look at this letter now I
could look at it three weeks from now
and that depends on whether you want to
leave this envelope on my desk CU you
walk out of the road exactly we have the
same thing we have the same thing but
the reason why I will not accept
corruption as the reason why we are poor
is because corruption is a symptom it's
a consequence of this system exactly and
I am just tired tired when it comes to
Africa especially that most people are
stuck at the symptoms the consequences
level we'll never get there otherwise so
we have to I don't know it's it's I know
that it's not sexy to look at laws to
think about laws for most people laws
are invisible and it's true and that's
what makes it so complicated it's an
invisible thing but everything around us
if you think about it often times is
ruled by regulations and some type of
laws so um so this is so when you talk
about corruption the reason why I uh I
hear many people like there 100 people I
told you about being lined up corruption
is going to be probably way up there and
I say no corruption is the sign that
there are too many laws and also too
many senseless laws because every time
that gentleman gets a chance to interact
with me this person from the state
interacts with me if I did not have to
deal with this person like it is in the
US there is no friction there is no
point there's no place um in in which
this person can exercise the power that
the state give them when the state said
to this person you get to decide if
Conant and myad can work together right
there right there you opened everything
up for corruption because this person
knows now that my fate depends on his
decision or her decision and so what
happens is they're just going to sit
there make things last longer than they
should and eventually that's what also
happens they they apply every single
piece of the law hoping that at some
point you get tired of it and eventually
it's just faster easier for you just to
pay a bribe and move on with your life
so corruption to me is is not a good
thing of course but it's an easy one to
fix remove the law remove um you know
the interaction between me and the state
official and you remove that opportunity
for corruption and bribe happening but
but the problem is as well with
corruption as someone whose mother comes
from one of the most corrupt nations in
the world which is venezuella is it it
becomes part of the culture and that's
really dangerous because I always think
corruption is like a cancer once it
starts to
metastasize you see the you see the you
see your country fall apart which is
partly what I've seen yes yes and
exactly what you're talking about um
Francis is the reason why one of my most
radical Solutions is basically around
this concept of startup cities I don't
know if you guys heard about them some
people call them B uh Charter cities but
basically these are Next Generation Um
special economic zones that have their
own law have their own governance and
also have custom regulatory framework
and so the reason why we suggest because
right now I'm involved also in polic in
um in policy reforms um so we're talking
about peace meal as ation as you all
know this takes time and by the time
you're by the time you manage to get one
law taken out or you know uh cleaned up
over here 20 million popped up over
there and it's an endless cycle
meanwhile I have hundreds of millions of
young people who come to an age of
working every single year in Africa and
have nowhere to turn this is a literally
a ticking bomb a ticking bomb um maybe
the Europeans see it in the form of all
the you know the U migrants um trying to
come to Europe The Americans and now we
know that some Africans are also using
um the um the um Central American routes
going to Nicaragua and from their
passing over to the US I ne I don't
personally blame those young people they
have done what humans have done
throughout times in my country right now
what they love is to pound on them you
know be like you should have more pride
and stay in your own country no no no
the story of humans is if here doesn't
work for you you go over there all of us
are results of of just and it's the most
healthy instinct to have so I am not mad
at I am sad I'm I'm I'm often times I'm
unconsolable even today you get up you
watch you you check for news every
single day there are news of boats
little Fisherman's boats bless you
leaving my country trying to make it to
Europe with tons of young people in them
and and I like to say our most
entrepreneurial people because who lives
this is a self-chosen group right these
are the ones we need back home and but
right now for most of them they're
laying at the bottom of the ocean
serving as fish food and I sit there and
I ask myself is this the best we can do
uh when they don't die like that you
find them bodies dropping from the plane
you know like uh because somebody
thought it was a good idea to hide in a
landing gear and somewhere above England
here where we are a body drops or you
open the cargo section of a plane and
you see a Frozen body because no one
told them that you know when he gets up
there things get really cold and they're
going to die and then when they think
that Air route is too dangerous sea
route is too dangerous then they're like
we're going to go land route and land
route so many of them get stuck in Libya
and in Libya right now when you when you
caught someone like me they sell you as
a slave for 300 between $300 and $500
silver misery but misery um so for me
it's just um I I I um I look at this and
I'm thinking to myself what are we going
to do what do we do so like I said I've
been working on pie on uh reforms but
that takes too long and the kids are not
waiting the kids are not waiting they're
like I've got a Life to Live I've got to
go now I got to try
this okay so what's the solution we have
to speed everything up we have to be
radical
and because trying to do things at the
national level takes forever we're like
how about on a smaller piece of land the
size of a city there we basically change
uh the rules of the game there we bring
to the local entrepreneurs the best
business environment that there is Al
Singapore or Al Denmark if not better
and we bring that to people right where
they are and from there you're almost
basically building this area where
people get to try before they buy and
for me this is very much um the future
sure this is very much part of a
solution because like you said um at
some
point corruption becomes part of it's
it's it's it's it's in everything and
you try to fight it you have people
fighting you back everywhere you have
all of these entrenched interests
fighting from everywhere you go nowhere
so it is smarter to do it this way and
then when it starts to work here what we
have also found is that actually all
these other oligarchs who used to uh
benefit from the system and were very
you know thriving in corruption
corrupted world all of a sudden they're
finding that oh wait first of all this
is extra business for me because now
there is activity going on here and on
top of that now they're starting to
convert slowly to the place where you
don't have to you don't need to know
anybody in order to thrive and they're
starting to to realize oh wow I actually
can make money in a manner where I don't
have to be um bonded to anyone uh you
know because a lot of them they're not
leaving the best lives you might see
them with with fancy homes fancy cars
and fancy but I
see I'm not going to say slaves because
you know but out of respect for the real
slaves but I see people that are not
free at the very minimum people that owe
everything that they have to these
governments there is a government in
West Africa I won't say a name here
where the president is quite known where
you go to the parties so all of these
people who benefit from his largesses
they have these great big big businesses
all crony business you know what he does
he'll invite you wife to go dance with
him you're sitting right there and he's
there touching her doing all the things
he wants to do to her and there's not
one single damn thing you can do about
it because you open your mouth or you
even Flinch your eyelashes out of you
know anger and the next day he'll send
you all the people the Auditors that are
going to come and tell you how much
taxes you actually owe them after all of
these years and everything else do you
really think people like that want to
continue like that so when you create
these zones all of a sudden they start
to see and even them eventually start to
con
So the plan is you do it somewhere where
there's actually almost nothing existing
and then from there you create a new
reality I call it I call these little
islands of excellence and then from
there you you watch the island of
Excellence become an inspiration for
other people and then they try to
imitate this what happened over here and
that's little by little how you get to
change everything around you so that
really is the path I've been on and I've
been promoting it for the past year on
the continent at first it was one
country that you know was very
interested and we had to do all the jump
through all the hoops and to interest
them and now I'm happy to say there's
four nations that we're talking to and
out of those one I think is ultra Ultra
Ultra promising and uh hopefully within
the next few months we'll be now able to
announce where we're doing this so I am
so bullish on the continent it's not
even a joke because we know that when
you do things like this it takes within
um 25 years we're talking about a
generation you can see the change
starting to happen so that's why my goal
is my stated goal is um by 20 uh 2.5
billion prosperous Africans by 2050
because that's how many we will be by
then so yeah that's um that's pretty
much what the plan
is we'll get you back to mgat in a
minute but first that my friends is the
sound of another sale on Shopify the
all-in-one Commerce platform to start
run and grow your business I know that
building a business takes work look at
my face I'm exhausted but the lovely
thing about Shopify is that no matter
how big you want to grow Shopify is with
you every step of the way Shopify is a
Commerce platform revolutionizing
millions of businesses worldwide whether
you're selling handmade jewelry art
prints or podcast merch like us bu our
merch Shopify simplify selling online
and in person so you can successfully
grow your business Shopify even gets you
selling across social media marketplaces
like Facebook Instagram and Tik Tok Tik
Tok just makes me angry I'm too old so
if you're ready to get serious about
selling sign up for A1 per month troll
period at
[Music]
shopify.com
do/ trigger and now back to the
interview and and I'm really I'm really
inspired by what you said because one of
the things I noticed when I in Venezuela
was we call it which means third world
third world attitude and it's and people
you know in the west would be like oh
that's a really horrible way to look at
it but it's true you know and
particularly when you look at politics
and these politicians all they care
about is reaching the top not because
they want to serve their Nation not
because they want to turn what should be
one of the richest countries in the
world World in terms of resources into
one of richest countries of the world
but all they care about is getting to
the top and enriching themselves that's
right that's right and you think to
yourself you look at it and you go well
it doesn't matter how rich your country
is it doesn't matter the potentiality a
country has you are always going to be
doomed to failing that's right that's
right yeah no very much and um so that's
why for me um you know it's very much my
attitude in life is criticized by
creating so it's like when something is
wrong of course put your finger on on
what's wrong so that you can because you
without a proper diagnosis you can't
really come to a right solution but
beyond that then get working on the
solution otherwise sit down and shut up
well I do think history is very
important because people
uh in order to control the future you
control the past right and the stories
that people are told about their own
history uh and the history of other
people and the history of the relations
between them uh are really important I
think in terms of uh people's sense of
who they are so uh I imagine if you tell
people constantly well you are where you
are because of colonialism or because of
slavery because of this it creates a
certain mindset and um do I I just want
to come back to that because is it
really true that colonialism you know
isn't really important in the history of
Africa in in the history of where Africa
is today and I'm always a first one to
say um did it have a big role in um in
in it absolutely absolutely
but um my problem
is if you you
know the thing is I always like to say
yes and right and not be stuck at we
cannot what happened there's nothing we
can we can do about that nothing and
denying what happened also is definitely
not where I'm coming from I'm the first
one to say yes this stuff happened and
it was violent among probably one of the
most violent
um colonizations that they were if if we
have to measure these things so
absolutely all of that happened just
like you know if you're born to um I
don't know drug drug addicted parents
whatever of course it's going to be part
of uh who you are today but that does
that control what you can do later for
yourself no I had this great friend of
mine he passed away but he said no
matter what happened to you you're
responsible for what you do for you and
I really really for me that's I'm trying
to extract our people from that place of
commiseration of this is what happened
to us of this was so wrong we we got to
depart from that
place however defining part of our
history of what it was and someone like
me I like to remind our
people there were Africans on that great
continent before the white man ever set
foot on the continent who were we what
were we doing what was our story and
when you look there and you look at the
work of people like Professor George
a great uh new um also historians that
are coming up and you can and you see
that Africa had some of the richest
empires of their times we don't know
this we don't think about this I in fact
I argue that for most people Africans
and non-africans the story of Africa
starts with slavery moves onto
colonialism to present day so we are
robbed from a very important time of our
history and when you look at that time
of our history Africans were practicing
the free enterprise we were free
marketeers trade routes among some of
them most vibrant in the world so that's
also part of my Birthright yeah have we
gotten derailed afterwards
yes yes does it play a role in who we
are today yes
yes but is that where the story
ends I guess some people would like it
to be that way uh what about the way we
have these conversations in the west
because obviously you're someone who's
come from Sagal and you live in the US
some of the time um and I imagine
because you have a certain skin color
people assume certain things about you
and want to sort of bring you into a
certain conversation yes how do you see
the way we talk about these issues in
the west you know con when um when I
came to Vis by the way I love the French
pronunciation of my name it's so
good con it's sexy I like it about
me yeah not sex FR
Frances it sounds sexier than Frances
yeah when we're in Austin that's all
anybody said to me or the Americans
Frances I know Americans and I keep
telling them you are the one with the
weird accent yeah they are actually they
are it's funny because when I first
moved to um to America that's when I
learned that actually the the English
that I learned was British and uh yes I
uh that's what we learned and the accent
everything so since I got to the us so
you learn correctly yes you're welcome
yes I
AG that is not a good
look spent half an hour talking about
slavery and colonal and then it's like
and then I'm like thank you yeah thank
you well you know if I that that part of
a language but um but anyway sorry we we
got no but you know when I came to visa
when I came to understand everything
that I understand today that I'm sharing
with you I literally lost 90% of my
friends I came from the left I I used to
belong to the left I was borderline
commi if you can believe that really yes
yes why because that's the that's that
was what you were taught or um because
because for the longest I've always
cared about people I've always cared
I've always cared about people I've
always care cared about um you know the
the the I don't know what the right word
is but maybe not the little people but
you know what I mean by that but I've
always cared about those Among Us who
are disadvantaged you know um and so for
the longest time I really believed what
um that side was saying what the
Socialists were saying I I I I I believe
that maybe it was the best chance for um
you know disadvantaged people I believe
and especially you know and yes back
then I used to think all the things that
I push back on today I used to think
that um yeah um colonialism is the
reason why we were where we were um the
fact that um our national our natural
resources are being you know literally
stolen is why where we are um maybe
racism maybe you know they just didn't
they the white people just didn't want
us to get some somewhere so I believed I
believed all of this for a long time and
um but what I discovered is once I
started running this business of mine um
the first time that's when I started to
really I saw the discrepancy between
running a business back home and running
a business in the US and at first I
think I thought to myself well of course
um we're poor that's why it's so hard
and conversely we're rich that's why
it's so easy just to come to understand
that relationship that I told you about
we're poor because we don't have enough
money at least not enough money to take
care of our basic needs where does money
come from for most of us it's a job
right and where do jobs come from the
the private sector for the most part and
so once you understand that and then you
realize that yeah and for companies to
be they need a good business environment
and you realize and here I am seeing
that it's so hard for me to do business
over
here that's when I was like wait a
second so the D started to connect and I
was like wait a second and so from that
moment on everything started to to
collide in my head because I was like
the people that I have been with this
whole time who were very um good at you
know conforting me in those thoughts of
victimhood in a way
they don't like business they think
business is evil yeah they do does that
not does that not is that not the
weirdest thing I find that so strange uh
and there's a lot of it here in England
there's a lot of it here in England they
you know uh on TV people talk constantly
about oh the 1% this and the 1% that and
I'm going they pay like a [__] ton of
tax for all the public services that we
enjoy and most of them look there's
crony capitalism course there is but
most of those people got to where they
got to by providing a service to other
people that those people want to pay for
exactly and yet these people hate them I
I I I can't get my head around it no and
um I can't either but at some point I
came to realize that there's probably
nothing to understand you know con when
I listen to these
people I saw something and I saw because
when I started to confront them why why
why as once upon a time I believed in
these ideas and I believed in your good
heart I believe that you to were into it
because of because you believed like me
that we with best chance that the global
poor had the global poor has always been
my concern because I come from a
continent that's known for that and that
needs to change
so I believed that you guys scared and
now that I'm confronting
you all I hear from you is something
rather ugly do you know what I hear from
them Envy yes Envy it's disgusting it's
disgusting it is immoral it's wrong I
all I could hear and all I could sense
was
envy and then I realized oh so I was a
coverup for you disgusting most vile
sentiment you were using me and my likes
to promote your stupid ideology that in
the end just goes to serve your
Envy that's when for me the left lost
their moral High Ground that's it I I
could I was done and um yeah and I guess
they were done with me as
well mgat there has been uh quite a
number of criticisms against France and
its relationship with the french-
speaking African countries and they say
that there have been a lot of criticisms
that France is quite a parasitic
relationship to these countries do you
agree with that do you
disagree I absolutely agree with that I
really do
[Music]
um most of our economy seems to be
controlled by um by the
French
but that's not how we correct the the
way we correct the situation interrupt
you there because you said most of our
economy has is been controlled by the
French can you tell people people like
me who have just just heard this and go
what do you mean by this yes so
basically um in my country Sagal for
example um you look at uh
the the Telecommunications Company it's
called
orange and it's what all Africans use
and basically we're talking about our
cell phones all of that I mean these
people are making billions of dollars
every single year and for the longest
time they were the only game in
town and you should see the crappy
service that we have had but that's what
happens I guess when you have a monopoly
right so um so there then um a lot of
our um gas stations owned by the French
as well even today the biggest um gr the
largest grocery store chain is called
oan so don't take me wrong U I think
they set it up as a franchise so yes
many sagales people are you know um they
own these franchises and they a lot of
people who are being employed it's um
business is happening so my point is not
that business is happening or not
happening business happening is always a
good thing but I think the reason why
people have such a big problem is in uh
looking at it and it seems like
everything is controlled by France which
in a way it is and I am sure that France
is probably playing its uh Power its um
its U hand in that also our currency is
is pegged against uh is pegged against
the the the Euro and France is there are
guarantors even before um even before
the euro was there our currency was not
printed in my country it's printed in
France and they keep a big Reserve back
there for you know guarantees and so
it's it's unbelievable even this
language that we're speaking I have a
problem with why is it that French
should be the our official language it
is our official language and then what
you see there is because I'm like if
we're going to have to speak another
language an international language
because I understand you know it's good
to pra to have an international language
because you can belong then to the
global scene of business and you you can
you can be included but France I mean
are you kidding me are you really
seriously kidding me is French really
going to be is it really a um a language
of international language of business
are you kidding me no but I feel like
we're trapped in that thing just because
of our ego when I hear someone like
jaali telling me a few years ago he's
like well by 2050 you know French is
going to be the third most spoken
language in the world I'm like oh yeah
because I know you R you're relying on
us Africans for that to happen because
we're the youngest continent in the
world 19 years old of age in average and
by 2050 one out of four people walking
this Earth will be African so I know
where is it that friends thinks they're
going to get their language to not die
it's gonna be thanks to us I'm like but
if I have anything to do with that
that's not going to happen thank you
very much because so right now so
anywhere from the language to um all of
our economy like some of the biggest
companies making the most money are
French and it's pretty much the same up
and down the frankophone you know
Corridor um but there again you ask me
and I say you know what prenal doing
exactly what
they should be I shouldn't even say they
should be doing they're doing exactly
what they get away what they can get
away with so I I'm not going to say
they're doing what they should be doing
I don't think actually what they're
doing is smart so I wouldn't even call
it what they should be doing I don't
think it's smart I don't think it's
right but they're doing what they can
get away with and as long as the rest of
us
are locked
out our country remains poor it remains
poor it means it has no s sovereignty
really has no sovereignty means it needs
to transfer to the people who bail it
out which is usually going to be France
for the most part you know the European
nations and some the us as well so as
long as you keep your loow your
entrepreneurs down and they can't they
can't um produce the wealth that all
nations that are prosperous rely on then
you are going to remain a poor nation
which means you have no sovereignty
which means you're entering to uh
foreign
entity a foreign government in this case
because foreign aid so this is also the
part that my fellow Africans I feel
don't really understand so their natural
instinct is we see this it doesn't look
right it doesn't feel right and then our
solution to this is we're going to do a
coup I'm sure you've been hearing about
the the you know resurgences of coups in
West Africa they're back and so the plan
there is we're going to kick these
people out who are responding to who are
basically the valet of France and then
we're going to have people in here who
are not going to be the valys of France
anymore and then voila things are going
to change well they're going to be The
Valleys of Russia and China now thank
you very
much thank you very much because what we
don't understand is that the only way to
be truly truly truly Sovereign is to
make your own money that's the only way
and until we get there we are always
always going to be under someone's
rule the sooner we understand that the
sooner we get to work and we know what
to do when it comes to get to work and
the sooner this gets corrected and like
I said within 25 years it can be a very
different story we'll be back with our
guest in a minute but first we want to
tell you about Factor we've discovered a
fantastic way to stay on track with your
nutritional goals while saving time if
you're in America and you're looking for
dieti approved Chef prepared fresh never
frozen meals to fuel you on jam-packed
days then you need to take a look at
factor factor is America's number one
ready to eat meal delivery service and
they'll help you eat well for breakfast
lunch and dinner with nutritious and
flavorful ready to eat meals delivered
straight to your door leave the calorie
counting to their dietitians and leave
the planning prepping and cleanup to
their chefs while you're out there
crushing it than are making sure each
meal has the nutrition you need and the
flavor you're looking for choose from
over 35 Chef crafted meals every week
that support a healthy lifestyle and
meet your meal preferences whether it's
vegan veggie Protein Plus or wholesome
options there are also calorie conscious
options that don't skimp on Flavor try
delicious dietitian approved calorie
smart meals that are under 550 calories
per serving the food is fresh and the
ingredient quality is on point for
example the meat is from grass-fed or
pasture raised animals and is free of
antibiotics hormones and GMOs it's high
quality stuff and you just have to run a
Google search to see how well Factor
comes out in reviews to try Factor head
to factor meals.com trigger 50 and use
code trigger 50 to get 50% off that's
code trigger 50 at factor meals.com to
get 50% off now back to the interview
how do you disentangle those roots M how
do you dis how do you stop your currency
being pegged against the Euro because
that is something that I've heard and
when I found out about it I was shocked
and we talk about you know modern day
colonialism in a way isn't that sort of
modern day Colonial it really is it it
is but again my point with all of that
is I have two things to say on
that
um first of all I want to put a caveat
in
this having your own
currency is that a good idea yes every
time it's possible I say be in control
of your own
currency in this situation though I
would like to say when you see what
happens to some of these nations that
have their own currency and what they do
I mean look again remember the 100
people that you line up and you ask them
why we where we are bad leaders corrupt
leaders they don't think about us They
Don't Care About Us these are the same
people that I've been hearing on TV when
you know we had the RIS um when we have
inflation all of that stuff and you know
what I hear them say oh well we during
covid they were watching what the West
was doing you know a printing machine
and they said you see we should have the
right we should have the ability to do
the same
thing except that us it would not have
happened just for covid it would have
been something that happened all the
time I mean you came from Venezuela you
know how that F works you you see what
happens in Zimbabwe you you see what
happens I mean there we're not talking
about you know 20% inflation of things
like we're talking about you know
hundreds 400s some parts of Sudan is not
even a joke yeah so that's what you know
when when you have irresponsible people
you know in charge of U currency that's
what they do that doesn't mean that I
I'm saying we should be under somebody
else's rule when it comes to our mon you
know tools that's not what I'm saying
but I also would like for our people to
remember that as well because right now
I wouldn't be surprised that a lot of
the Frank ofan African nations if they
had their own currencies they would be
crying probably more than uh the
Nigerians are crying in Nigeria with
vanira right and everybody's looking for
dollars under under the under cover so
that's the thing about currency now it
doesn't mean that we should be the way
what I advocate for forget being pegged
to anything forget fiat currency I don't
trust fiat currency period This Is Why
I'm big time on bitcoin something like
Bitcoin because fat currencies don't
have the the qualities that a good
currency has especially when it comes to
sound money we don't have sound money
anywhere around the world you look at it
so for me this is a place where again
Africans are going to need to Leap Frog
forget jumping on on some type of fat
currency just so later to exactly the
same problem we're having all over the
world with fed currencies and then be
thinking about you know cryptos or some
and in my case I believe really bit in
Bitcoin so in so for me it's like today
if we want to get rid of
that make it that Bitcoin is legal
tender along with anything else that
people might want give give people a
choice and this is really something that
our country it's a matter of it's a it's
a political will signs sign somewhere
but you want to get rid of that but our
people instead of uh understanding and
putting the pressure where it needs to
be put it's all about we're just going
to destroy everything put in place some
people who are you know like um these
military people through a coup and let's
watch things happen Mali has been um
they have they had their coup more than
I think two years ago baso had a coup on
top of a coup what changes am I seeing
there not really um ner just had one
recently and their big plan was oh are
you know without us France can't make it
because you know they rely on our
uranium you know without us yeah we're
going to sit on this and you're singing
what happen well guess what the french
are like now making multi-billion dollar
deals with some other nations because
guess what we don't have a monopoly of
Natural Resources some people are just
keeping it in their ground because they
don't need to have access to it yet and
but if you want to mess with them over
here they go somewhere else and they do
that and I think Africans have not
understood that yet what kills me the
most is this African belief that oh if
we just sit on our natural resources we
first of all the plan is let's become
one I'm like aren't you the same people
who are always complaining about the
leaders and now you're telling me that
the whole fate of the whole continent is
going to be into the hands of one of
these people really at least now when
the Chinese want to buy us or the
Russians want to buy us they have to go
and negotiate country by country by
country they have to do the dance 54
times and out of those 54 Nations some
are like no thank you very much others
are like yeah here is my newborn on top
of that as a you know as a as a bonus
what you know what I mean it's all over
the place but now you're going to make
it that one person gets to sell all of
us at once because that's what's going
to that's what's going to happen unless
you're telling me that maybe you will be
the leader of this and because you're so
good you're so saintly um it's all going
to run properly don't you worry and even
if that was the case you forgot that
power corrupts absolute power absolutely
corrupts so this idea of one Africa
speaking with one voice is going to make
us stronger and then when we get to that
one Africa then we sit on our natural
resources we tell people you cannot
touch on natural resources this is a
price we command and or you have to
produce here and think that the world is
going to follow on that you know this
it's just wakanda nonsense I mean
seriously but that's where so many of us
are stuck and this is a big problem and
so these are the same people that have
an issue with me when I say Africa is
not poor because of colonialism but my
God is there not a contradiction in what
you're saying because on the one hand
you say Africa is not poor because of
colonialism but on the other hand when
Francis asked you about French influence
yeah isn't that what people mean by the
legacy of colonialism I um I think
that's what they mean but I think
they're wrong in
that because my point is anytime we
could have done this anytime we could
have done this constant anytime anytime
over the past 60 years we could have
without even touching orange because see
that's the other thing for me it's not
about you destroy orange you kick total
out you kick all of this ocean out
that's not and then business as usual
that's not how we're going to become
we're going to get anywhere we're
actually seeing them doing
that when you look at burina Faso more
or less they have kicked the French out
what do they have to show for themselves
right now Mal the malons have done more
or less the same thing what do they have
to show for themselves
I guarantee you that unless anything
changes six years from now it's going to
be the same but except like you said the
Russians are the ones coming in right
now so next next what is it going to be
all the Russians are Nuclear So my point
is yes the French control a lot of the
economy but that's not the reason why
we're poor remember again Conan go back
with me you poor be poverty is solved by
Prosperity Prosperity is built by
entrepreneurs you are not allowing your
entrepreneurs to
create when the friends show up what
you're doing for them is here is the red
carpet the nonsense laws that myad has
to deal with you don't have to deal with
it the nonsense laws that myad has to
contem with all all of these tariffs um
when she brings up her product you we
made a negotiation with you that you're
not going to have to put up with that
they give you all types of exoneration
but to me they don't and I am the one my
country needs
me and others like me but we are
excluded from the forces that allow us
to release our magic of building
something out of nothing which is what I
call entrepreneurs entrepreneurs are
those who criticize by creating and
those who create something out of
nothing you don't allow me to
create so what's left and so if I'm not
creating we as a nation state poor when
a big Corporation shows up which is what
total is Orange is all of these
companies are C Cola whatever when they
show up you deploy the red carpet for
them because like oh my God we needed
you we needed you because we're so poor
we want you to come and create these
jobs over here when you have completely
overlooked me over here so what you're
talking about is essentially people are
having the Wrong conversation it's not
whether colonialism was good or bad of
course it was bad it's that talking
about it is not actually changing
anything it's making people feel like
victims it's actually making them
victims in the future because you're not
creating the wealth yourself and then as
you say when the big corporations come
in you need their money because you've
been brainwashed into being with victim
this entire time exactly because you're
focusing on the past instead of the
future exactly okay you got it that's
exactly my point that's the point I'm
trying to make and it's just people are
just stuck where they are and um but
it's okay Conant fris it's okay do you
know why it's okay because it only takes
one to 5% of the world to 1 to 5% of
people to change the world for good or
for bad that to me is the great promise
so while the masses are all busy crying
out loud all day that God makes I am out
there the reason why I'm even doing
these podcasts with you guys and I have
this B we're Brin yeah and you're a big
fan of the show and I'm a big I mean
come on let's say it like it is speak
the
truth there you go no but you know the
reason why I'm doing this I'm putting
myself out there and I have this book
coming up uh November 1th it's called
the heart of AA the reason why I'm doing
all of this is because I'm putting
myself out there with this message and
the and the idea is to light the beacon
of um The Beacon of light and for
like-minded people to see the message
and we want to build this place for them
and I want them to all com start
congregating I'm looking for the cheetah
I'm looking for them all around the
world and as we congregate and we form
the Coalition that's how a pack of
cheetah is called then uh we go and we
now go for the Run of our lives and for
me those are the people that are going
to change um Africa and the reason why
we call it theeta we we we have this
reference to Veta is because of
Professor a George a who is one of my
intellectual favs and he's the one who
saw that um Africa was going to get
where she needs to get to thanks to the
cheetas these are the fast Runners of
Africa it's a mindset mentality we are
not there waiting for anybody we are the
ones who are going to get it done for
ourselves so but I'm looking for the 1
to 5% it might sound very elitist but
that's who I'm looking for because we
know the rest of the world is followers
and they will at first make fun of us
like they have you know first they've
been making fun of me now some people
are also
um um no first they ignored me they
ignore
you I'm right now in this phase where
make they're making fun still some
ignoring some still making fun we know
the next step is going to be attacks y
and then after Ville we win so I'm right
where I need to be but I'm looking for
my one to five% and once I get them all
we go we're going to have a run of Our
Lives we're going to run in Leaps and
Bounds the way a cheatah runs because
like I like to say the time for catching
up is over now is the time for Leap Frog
so that's pretty much what the plan is
but I'm so glad Conant you made that um
clarification because that's really I
think one of the tensions we're having
out there you know because they're like
we're still colonized that's why we get
nowhere and I'm like whatever is going
on now has nothing to nothing to do with
the fact that you're still poor and it's
just a Wrong conversation it's a Wrong
conversation well I'm glad we had the
right conversation my thank you so much
for coming on uh head on over to locals
where we continue the conversation with
your questions from a
gat does the CCP belt and Road
initiatives in African countries improve
wealth prospects or reduce them for
those countries where they are
implemented
[Music]